[Aplausos]
olá a todos
meu nome é paloma e eu quero começar
essa história contando pra vocês que eu
sou filha de pasteleiros do tuta e da
van que ele era um dos meus maiores
presentes que é o meu irmão vinícius a
nossa família ela nunca teve boas
condições financeiras e por isso desde
pequena eu aprendi o poder que o ensino
e até na minha vida
os meus pais olhavam os meus cadernos
todos os dias depois da aula
eu era uma criança incomodada
incomodada com as coisas do dia a dia eu
ficava incomodada quando eu vi alguém na
rua sem casa ou quando eu vi alguém
sendo menosprezado pelas suas condições
financeiras
aquilo tudo me incomodava mas nem
comandava na minha cabeça de criança
ficava só lá dentro
um tempo depois eu entrei no cursinho
popular da minha cidade
lá os meus professores eles eram alunos
do ita que vinham de vários lugares do
brasil
então eles começaram a me mostrar que eu
podia sonhar com coisas que eu nem
imaginava que eu podia sonhar em muito
além
então entendi que aquele incômodo que eu
tinha quando eu era criança eu podia
usar na minha profissão que eu escolhi
fazer relações internacionais que quando
era pequena eu assistia no jornal até as
pessoas trabalhando na onu e elas
mudavam mundo e achava que o fantástico
e eu também queria aquilo então isso vem
muito naquele ano nos professores me
ajudaram muito e eu fui aprovada
precisará na universidade federal do abc
eu lembro até hoje quando eu cheguei em
casa eu fui contar para o meu pai e ele
estava lá que tinha sido aprovada
aquilo foi uma emoção muito grande
porque ninguém da minha casa nunca tinha
feito graduação
a gente estava muito feliz mas quando
você não tem dinheiro a primeira coisa
que vem à sua cabeça é
e como você vai fazer para se manter na
universidade
aquilo que quebrou meu coração e quebrou
dos meus pais mas não logo depois eu
descobri que existia um instituto que
ele dava dinheiro para jovens de baixa
renda estudarem na universidade
a primeira coisa que passou na minha
cabeça foi uma desconfiança
como assim alguém te dar dinheiro sem
pedir nada em troca
aquela foi a primeira coisa que eu
pensei mas resolvi tentar
então eu me inscrevi e eu fui
selecionada para ser uma das bolsistas
quando cheguei no primeiro encontro
desse instituto desse instituto
eu descobri que lá eles faziam várias
analogias de plantas e sementes porque é
instituto semear então tinha toda uma
criatividade desenvolvida e um dos
fundadores veio conversar com a gente e
ele falou dentro de vocês
existe uma sementinha e alça está
esperando para ser desabrochada e aqui
nós somos a água que vai regar essa
sementinha para aquela desabroche e gere
muitos frutos
eu achei que o lindo mas ainda não
estava convencido era meio difícil então
veio mais é fundador e ele já era mega
bem sucedido já tinha própria empresa
ele falou pra gente aqui dentro daquela
sala ele acreditava que estava um dos
próximos presidentes ou presidenta do
brasil
quando olhei pro lado eu estava
esperando que todo mundo tá tão
assustado quando eu tava mais
incrivelmente as pessoas estavam muito
animadas elas estavam muito felizes e eu
fui me contagiando resumo da história eu
saí de lá decidido é que eu ia marcar
alguma coisa na história e mais do que
isso de que eu ia se a água pra outra
semente na então eu aprendi quais eram
aquelas linhas escondidas no cma
então as aulas começaram na ufpb c
eu achei que eu não ia encontrar pessoas
que também queriam mudar um lenço ahmed
tarde mas acreditem eu encontrei e não
só me encontrei como me juntei a eles
as pessoas olhavam pra gente lava esses
jovens trabalham 40 horas por semana e
ele
não ganhou nada em troca é tudo doido
naquela hora eu realmente acreditei que
nós éramos dois mas nós éramos dois com
propósito
nós éramos o time natos o fbc a gente
queria tirar projetos em comunidades em
vulnerabilidade discurso bonito né
então a gente vai começar nosso primeiro
projeto a gente só tinha contato em
contato nem da comunidade espera do
líder da associação de moradores
ele levou a gente para conhecer uma
parte da comunidade chamada fazendinha
lá eu conheci uma mãe vou chamá-la de
ram
a rosa criava oito filhos sozinha então
ela me chamou para ir até a casa dela e
eu topei
chegamos lá eu descobri que a rosa e os
oitos filhos morava em um barraco
o barraco ele era feito de restos de
papelão de lona e madeira
então entrei naquele lá dentro não tem
piso
naquele dia tinha chovido muito então lá
dentro era tudo ama e aquilo estava
estragando tudo que tinha dentro da casa
dela
o barraco ele era bem pequena mas a cada
passo que a gente dava um monte de
moscas subia no chão naquele momento só
passava uma coisa na minha cabeça
a palavra dignidade
eu não conseguia aceitar que a rosa e os
oitos filhos tinha que viver naquela
situação
a gente descobre que desigualdade social
tem cep no brasil ela tem remetente tem
rua tem estado e que dignidade
quer dizer tem poder de escolha porque
eu tenho certeza que a rosa nunca
escolheria passar por aquilo com os
filhos não
então a gente percebeu que a gente tinha
que fazer alguma coisa
a gente se reuniu com outros moradores
da comunidade ea gente decidiu que a
gente vai fazer uma horta comunitária
então veio a primeira pergunta onde a
gente vai fazer esta horta e só tinha um
lugar na comunidade que era livre
era um terreno baldio que basicamente
servia de lixão
adicione várias pessoas de natas várias
pessoas da comunidade a gente foi pra lá
no começo achei que aquilo nunca ia dar
certo
a gente achou pele de cobra rato fralda
suja e um monte de outras coisas mas
depois de uma semana aquele terreno já
não tinha mais lixo pesado então a gente
passou para a segunda etapa era capinar
agora olha pra qualquer estudante e
passa na cabeça de vocês que algum deles
sabe que a pna
pois é a gente não sabia mas a gente
tinha muita força de vontade
a gente criou então depois de algumas
semanas uma horta e ela começou a render
frutos e aqueles moradores estavam
podendo consumir daquilo com sua família
e também vender para os vizinhos deles
então uma senhora que tinha mais ou
menos 70 anos ela se aproximou de nós e
falou vocês não imaginam o quanto está
mudando a minha vida porque agora eu
tenho motivo para sair da cama e aquela
depressão já está cada vez menor
aquilo mexeu muito comigo
a gente tem que parar de reclamar do
restaurante universitário do ônibus de
coisas banais do nosso dia a dia e usar
os nossos privilégios para fazer alguma
coisa para o mundo
então chegou o momento no ano que é o
campeonato nacional onde a gente vai
apresentar os nossos projetos pra outras
pessoas outros times da nato todo mundo
vai lá apresentar o seu projeto eo líder
da associação de moradores me chamou e
falou
caprichem que eu quero ver na telona
naquele momento você já imaginou como a
gente estava se sentindo responsável
então a gente foi pra fortaleza
apresentar os nossos projetos ea gente
nunca vai esperando
alguma coisa em troca mas naquele ano a
gente foi campeão nacional daquele
campeonato não só com esse projeto mas
também com outros projetos que a gente
fazia na rede de saúde mental a
felicidade gigantesca em subir ocorrendo
no palco um monte de estudantes gritando
era só festa ea gente só consegue
imaginar o quanto aquilo podia aumentar
a visibilidade do que a gente fazia dos
nossos projetos
então aqueles dois com propósito foram
representar o brasil no campeonato
mundial no canadá e aquilo foi uma das
experiências mais dois que a gente já
teve
naquele momento eu comecei a perceber a
força que a coletividade tinha a gente
voltou e meu ciclo na que estava
terminando
eu comecei a seguir outro caminho mas eu
não esperava que fosse sentir aquela
força da coletividade de novo tão forte
e tão rápido
surgiu uma oportunidade de um grupo
selecionando jovens a representarem o
brasil em uma assembléia na onu na hora
comecei a minha inscrição nossa é isso
comecei e dois minutos depois eu
descobri que aquela participação estava
15 mil reais 15 mil
eu pensei não vai ter pra mim eu não vou
participar mas eu vou terminar minha
inscrição para saber como esse processo
e adivinha eu fui selecionada aquele
momento não cabia de tanta felicidade e
eu queria contar para o mundo inteiro
então fui correndo pra minha mentora foi
contar pra ela eu falei você não
acredita a minha mentora do instituto
semear não acredita eu passei eu estou
muito feliz porque eu as relações
internacionais querem mudar o mundo tem
tudo a ver comigo mas eu não vou poder
participar
então a resposta dela você vai sim eu
falei não vou
você vai você vai sim eu falei então eu
vou e eu acredito até hoje como aquelas
pessoas elas têm o poder de fazer
acreditar eu conseguiria coisa que nem
eu nem imagino
ava então imagina a minha cara e não
contar para os meus pais eu fazer um
papel de fã tima back on line para reúne
15 mil reais em 11 dias
eu só tinha 11 dias naquele momento eu
comecei a me sentir de novo uma
sementinha sendo carregada pelo
instituto
a gente era uma rede tão grande que nada
nem ninguém era grande o suficiente pra
gente pedir ajuda ea gente começou a
movimentar em jornal e universidade em
prefeitura este movimento a gente no
brasil inteiro e juntos a gente
conseguiu bater a meta em agosto do ano
passado eu fui para nova york e praxe
tom eu passei pela onu pelo fmi pelo
banco mundial
e naquele momento entendi que eu não
tava só me representando estava
representando vários outros jovens que
não tiveram a oportunidade de estar lá
mas que também sonhavam com um brasil
mais justo eu me conectei com gente do
mundo inteiro a gente pode trocar várias
experiências e falar sobre os desafios
globais pensar em soluções transversais
hoje quando eu paro pra olhar pra trás
pra minha história e para tudo isso que
está acontecendo
vivem algumas coisas na minha cabeça
qual o futuro é prometido para jovens da
periferia
antes mesmo de eles começarem o que
esperam de nós
até onde a filha de pasteleiros pode aí
isto acontece por causa do sef que a
gente nasceu por causa do lugar onde a
gente cresceu das expectativas que foram
colocadas pra gente
esperavam que eu não fosse entrar numa
universidade
muito menos uma pública esperava que eu
vou trabalhar em qualquer lugar ou até
mesmo cuidar de casa
naquele momento eu entendi o poder do
nosso eu entendi a força que aqueles
jovens 22 tinha naquele momento eu
entendi o poder que a coletividade tinha
de fazer com que pessoas sem perspectiva
e sem poder sonhar conquistassem coisa
gigantes como fazer uma horta
comunitária ou como e representar o
nosso brasil internacionalmente
hoje com 22 anos
eu entendo que muita gente me ajudou
para chegar até aqui que muita gente
contribuiu para que eu conquistasse
tantas coisas tanto as vivências
mas eu quero ir além e agora eu me
coloco à disposição para também fazer
isso por vocês porque se for pra si para
chegar lá a gente vai chegar lá juntos
obrigado
[Aplausos]